so when you see failure as a means to
growth you become
immune to failure if you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
or feelings have become the means of
thinking by very definition of emotions
you're thinking in the past
when we learn to make those right
choices
we learn to live a transformed happy
fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems
that are going on around us
[Music]
nothing is permanent maybe at this phase
this age i'm adam
i'm 50 years old as i'm recording this
video for you and i wish
someone would have grabbed my shoulders
and shaken me
when i was in my 20s and 30s to let me
know that
all emotions even really high amazing
ones and
really crappy ones when you're at the
lowest of your low
aren't permanent you have to look at it
like you know they call it a hockey puck
in business
like hockey puck is like doing all the
effort energy investment and you're
going down right a hockey puck is down
and then up right
it's like it's like all the energy to
start a business the funds the setting
it up the mistakes that's going down
then all of a sudden you get momentum
and boom you get to you get the
skyrocket of the longer part of the
hockey stick going up
but when no one tells you is at the end
of the higher part of the hockey stick
it goes down again and then up and then
down and then up and that's really
the way life is i mean think about it
you don't know short unless you know
tall you don't know hot
unless you know cold you don't know
happy unless you know
sad you don't know ecstatic like
over the moon excited unless you
probably know a little bit of depression
so i think it's designed by god by the
universe that
you don't get to have the success the
happiness
unless you go through the crap so
whatever you're going through right now
know that it won't last
especially if you take action to make
sure it doesn't
especially if you write down what your
compelling future is
what if you wrote down what you're no
longer to accept again
in the situation you're in whether it's
the job the boyfriend the friends like
set boundaries so it's the learning
lesson so the curve comes down and you
learn but it'll come back again
and i think here's the other side
happiness the ecstatic perfect family
around
kids great that doesn't last either and
i don't mean that to i'm not trying to
be depressed
depressing what i want to say is be
grateful and
cherish the moments overlook the stupid
stuff in life don't worry about the
things that when you're 90 if you looked
back you'd say
why the hell did i waste a moment
worrying about that like if you're in a
moment if you're in a space if you're in
a place right now
maybe things are going great with your
boyfriend or girlfriend great with your
job great with your income
great with your career great with your
health you know what
know that it probably won't last forever
so take it in be grateful pray to god
appreciate what you have go to bed say
your prayers or practice gratitude
because we live in this hockey stick
environment and that's okay
you'd much rather live in that hockey
stick environment so you understand the
opposite of happiness the
back and forth cold hot short tall happy
sad right complexity craziness
happiness abundance you'd rather live
there
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being
so the person's entire state of being
when they start their day is in the past
so what does that mean the familiar past
will sooner or later be predictable
future
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
or feelings have become the means of
thinking by very definition of emotions
you're thinking in the past
and for the most part you're going to
keep creating the same life so then
people grab their cell phone
they check their what's up they check
their texts they check their emails they
check
facebook they take a picture of their
feet they post it on facebook they tweet
something they do instagram
they check the news and now they feel
really connected to everything that's
known in their life
and then they go through a series of
routine behaviors
they get out of bed on the same side
they go to the toilet they get a cup of
coffee they take a shower they get
dressed they drive to work the same way
they do the same things they see the
same people
that push the same emotional buttons and
that becomes
the routine and it becomes like a
program so now they've lost their free
will
to a program and there's no unseen hand
doing it to them
so when it comes time to change the
redundancy of that cycle
becomes a subconscious program so now
95 of who we are by the time we're 35
years old
is a memorized set of behaviors
emotional reactions unconscious habits
hardwired attitudes beliefs and
perceptions
that function like a computer program so
then
person can say with their five percent
of their conscious mind
i want to be healthy i want to be happy
i want to be free
but the body is on a whole different
program so then how do you begin to make
those changes well
you have to get beyond the analytical
mind because what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind
is the analytical mind and that's where
meditation comes in because you can
teach people
through practice how to change their
brain wave slow them down
and when they do that properly they do
enter the operating system where they
can begin to make some really important
changes
so most people then wait for crisis or
trauma or disease
or diagnosis you know they wait for loss
some tragedy to make up their mind to
change and my message is why wait and
and you can learn and change in a state
of pain and suffering or you can learn
and change in a state of joy and
inspiration i think right now
the cool thing is that people are waking
up when
life was in the other forms of life that
you see on the planet
nature determined a certain compulsive
instinctive ways of functioning
once you become human these lines have
been removed
you can act consciously that means
what you call as human potential is not
of any
kind of measurable limit it can go as
far
as you desire or us as far as you have
the courage to walk
so when we say human potential
unleashing human potential
it is not about reaching the peak
it is a trajectory
because what our life is
is a combination of a certain amount of
time and energy
time is rolling away for all of us at
the same pace
if you sit it rolls away if you sleep it
rolls away if you do something it goes
away if you don't do anything it goes
away
you're happy or miserable it goes away
time is running out for all of us so
it's only the energy that you can
do different things with if you bring
your energies to a certain level of
intensity
and possibility
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
this means if you live here for 100
years
it feels like in people's impact that
you've created
it feels like you lived here for a
thousand years simply because
you have managed your life energies in a
certain way
so for me a human being being impactful
means
how conscious have you become this is
very important because if you're in
compulsive cycles
then your energy gets wasted in so many
things
if you observe people in a day let's say
let's take 24 hours in that anyway most
people by prescription in america they
sleep for eight hours
[Laughter]
so eight hours means one third of life
is gone
in the remaining two thirds they have to
eat they have to
you know shower bathroom this that
all this another two three hours gone
so literally 50 of life is gone
daily basis just for basic maintenance
of this life
fifty percent of the time is gone in
maintenance remaining fifty percent what
they have
if you look at every single move that
they may
make with their body their thought
process their emotions
you will see a whole lot of it is
happening in compulsive cycles
or in other words if you are a little
sensitive to life
you will realize you are the biggest
issue in your life
so this is one thing that i'm trying to
do with people
that you are never the issue in your
life
i'm not the issue my thought my emotion
my body
is never the issue my thought my emotion
my energy and my body are my instruments
of function they are not impediments in
my life
but i would say for 90 of the human
beings their own body
then the compulsions of the body the
compulsions of their thought the
compulsions of their emotions
are ruling them most of the time so when
you yourself are a problem
well your own self-help if your business
fails
it doesn't matter did you grow if your
business succeeds it doesn't matter
did you grow and i found that really
liberating
because i was feeling like a failure for
failing consistently
but when rao changed my mental model and
he he uses the word mental model
i started seeing failure as simply a
means to growth
so when you see failure as a means to
growth you become
immune to failure and that is the real
beauty here
so rouse rule is also best illustrated
in this
this this really cool quote i had i saw
a friend share on instagram
and it says this grow so fast your old
friends have to get to know you all over
again
so i want to introduce you to a term
right i call it rose
rate of self evolution your rate of self
evolution
your rate of self evolution or your rose
must be the ultimate thing in your life
in other words your life needs to be
about personal growth
many of us forget that we make our life
about
our children that's wrong if you look at
the concept of conscious parenting which
shafali sabari teaches
your children are nothing more than the
vehicle for your greatest evolution
she shefali who has been on oprah seven
times says you are not there to teach
your children
your children are souls to teach you
likewise your work and your business is
not there for the title or the money
no those are [ __ ] constructs from
the culturescape you will get that
if you make your business about making
you grow so
personal growth becomes everything i'm
going to tell you some absolute
secrets of people who appear to be
naturally disciplined then no i've
worked with
many many olympic athletes they don't go
yay it's snowing and get up
and go out and train today they have to
keep saying i want
that olympic medal and this is the price
i'm going to pay to get the olympic
medal
so before you begin to adopt
self-discipline take a minute and think
what do i want what do i really
really really want and then answer
another question what
price would i pay to get what i want do
you want a great relationship
well you have to go out you can't sit at
home you've got to go out and interact
with people
you want a great job you've got to go
for some interviews
but there are some actually keys that
very very
disciplined people have and here is the
most important one and this
would change your life if you do it and
i had to make myself do this it was not
natural at all you must do
what you don't want to do first
people who are hugely successful do this
they do the thing they hate first of all
i worked with somebody who was morbidly
obese
and i said you know you have to work out
when i hate working out you know i'm
heavy it's really uncomfortable i said
no not only have you got to do it
you got to do it first and i had to do
that too you see if you don't like going
to the gym you go i'll go later
then something happens the phone rings
you eat something you think i was too
late now
when you go first you think later oh
i've been i went to the gym first
i feel like a winner you got to make a
very
difficult call you got to ring someone
who owes you money
or confronts someone that you don't want
to confront and you wait
and all day it's hanging over your head
making you feel so bad
when you do it first you feel like a
winner
because people who have discipline do
this they do
the thing they do not want to do
first and i want you to start saying
that i was giving a speech recently and
the guy who came on
after me said you know i kept hearing my
voice about going marissa said do what
you don't want to do first he said that
has changed my entire
business life and all my staff remember
that too what do we not want to do
what's the worst job let's do that first
and get it out of the way so that is
secret one to having incredible
self-discipline tell yourself make
yourself
do what you don't want to do first
and of course in the beginning this will
be what you do but you know what will
happen
it starts to become who you are it
becomes
easy it becomes seamless it's a bit like
putting
lenses in your eye it feels seriously
odd to suddenly jam your finger in your
eye
but if you do it every day comes easy
because that's how habits are formed you
make a habit
and then your habits make you to make
your habits
amazing so you've got habit one here is
habit two
take action every single day
in the direction of your goals and that
doesn't mean
work for 10 hours a day but even on a
saturday or a sunday
if you're building your business spend
five minutes
answering one email making one call
because that's what winners do they
don't have a day off when they are on
their way to success
they take action every single day
in the direction of their goals and
here's point three and it possibly is
the most
important point of all delay
gratification
delay the reward you see years ago we
went to work and our boss would go hey
good job you did really well today but
now a lot of us
don't have a boss we work for ourselves
we work from home
you may be a coach or a marketer
[Music]
you don't have a boss praising you
without praise
your praise muscle never really grows
what happens when you work for yourself
is halfway through
you stop and you do something and what
you have to do in the morning is go
right i
love my cappuccino but i'm going to do
something first
make six calls send out an email
then the cappuccino is my reward in the
journey of life as well
the takeoff which is our birth
is completely beyond our control we
didn't choose our parents
we didn't choose which nation we were
born in we didn't choose which city we
were born in
we didn't choose a socio-economic class
we were born in
we didn't choose our looks we didn't
choose the religion we were born in
our takeoff of the journey of life was
completely beyond us
and the lending death
even that will be completely beyond us
i've heard many times people telling me
that they would just love to die
by getting a massive heart attack and
dropping dead
no trouble for them no hospitalization
no tubes no needles no trouble cause to
others
in one shot go now
no matter how much we might wish that
it's just beyond us how we go
and how the landing happens is
completely beyond us
and what about the turbulence the
disturbances
the problems during the journey of our
life
some of them are within our control
which we can solve
for many problems and issues and the
turbulence cost is completely beyond our
control because it's caused by
situations which are beyond us it's
caused by
people who are beyond us
yes ladies and gentlemen in this journey
of life the takeoff
the landing and the turbulence is not in
our control
what is in our control however is the
choices we can make
and therefore spirituality
is about learning how to make
those right choices
when we learn to make those right
choices
we learn to live a transformed happy
fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems
that are going on around us
it is said when we are beautiful
it's god's gift to us when we live our
life beautiful
it is our gift to god therefore
being a male is a matter of birth
being a man is a matter of age
being a gentleman is a matter of choice
and as a corollary to that being a
female
is a matter of birth being a woman
is a matter of age being a gentle woman
is a matter of choice let us all
take to spiritual wisdom learn to make
the right choices which
are within our control as our gift to
god
and thus live our lives
as thorough and perfect ladies
and gentlemen now i've got some special
bonus clips that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you one of the ways
i've been disciplining my mind recently
is trying to reframe
anything negative and telling myself
it's the best
this has been a kick i've been on for
the past couple months that whenever
something bad happens
i tell myself it's the best and so this
came
out of me going to clamor con as an
event in palm springs and i met up with
a fan of mine leo
who is an awesome dude and he was going
to film something with me
we wanted to drive him to the desert
which is about an hour outside of palm
springs and he met me
on this insanely hot day you know 90
plus
degrees and he tells me evan it's super
hot outside
do you still want to go for this
hour-long trip into the desert say yes
let's do it lee i'm pumped let's go is
what i came for
you know i'm excited to see you let's do
it then he says well
also my air conditioning is broken
and we won't have any ac for the whole
trip
like let's do it this is the best let's
go i'm down i want to do it let's keep
going it's like
and we can't roll the windows down
because
if we're filming it'll really ruin our
audio so we gotta
we gotta sit in this car in this van the
whole time and not have any ac
or windows yes leo i want to do it let's
go this is the best i want to go let's
do it come on come on
as soon as we get outside of the airport
already i'm already feeling heat i'm a
canadian
not used to the crazy 90 plus degree
weather we get into his car
and just sitting in the car for two
seconds i'm already sweating i'm already
feeling the heat
like this is amazing this is the best
that reframe this is the best i'm so
pumped to do it
and we start driving and as we start
driving
it gets so hot that the camera shuts
down the camera malfunctions because it
got overheated
so we decided to get out on the street
on this stretch of the highway
and film the videos there and there's
barbed wire fences and there's
bottles of pee on the floor and there's
a dildo on the ground and
all of this crazy stuff happening it's
like this is the best this is amazing i
love it
and then we went from filming there to
filming at the youtube event
where we're in this huge room and
they're giving away all sorts of free
stuff
and just a dichotomy of this super
negative
crazy chaos environment to this
luxury one where you're getting a whole
bunch of free stuff i love both
here's what i think i think negativity
is coming for you right i think
i lean in on a positive it's amazing all
of the great stuff that happens
is the best too but when the negative
stuff does happen
it's not that you seek it it's not that
you're looking for it's not that you
want to invite it into your life
but when negativity does happen what do
you do
how do you react what do you think i
choose to discipline my mind to say when
that negativity comes i want to react in
a positive way
there's nothing neither good nor bad but
thinking makes it so
i want to react in a positive way i want
to see this as this is the best
this is my chance to shine we're gonna
have an amazing time through this chaos
i love it it's gonna be a great
experience well then people say okay
awesome you know you have to sit in a
sweaty car
that's the best okay i get it but what
happens when there's some really big
pain that happens we're not just talking
about
waiting for an elevator or standing on a
red light where one little thing didn't
go right in your schedule that day what
happens when
your business fails what happens when
you want to quit what happens when
something major happens in your life
i honestly think but that's the best too
i'm a big believer that your purpose
comes from your pain i think if i didn't
struggle and suffer so much and started
my business
i wouldn't be doing this the total lack
of self-confidence and self-worth that i
had in the early days of my business
and feeling like i'm putting in all this
work and all this effort and nothing is
working out
that is the reason why i do what i do
now
my individual pain and suffering is now
the reason why i'm out helping millions
of people
and i think it's the same thing for you
i think your purpose comes from your
pain i think if
if you have not been through pain it's
really hard to have a strong purpose
if you look at the people who you look
up to who are on a mission
who have a deep purpose they want to
change the way something is done
it's because of a deep pain that they
came from and i think ultimately humans
are good
i think people are good i think you want
to serve
i think when you've been through
something and you've come out on the
other side you naturally want to help
other people who are going through it
now i want to help entrepreneurs out so
much because i still
feel the 19 year old version of me
struggling
and suffering and i want to help that
guy out and i want to help
you guys out so even when you get hit
with some big news not just as little
tiny
okay you got to deal with hot weather
but big news that causes deep pain
still the best if you can reframe it to
say this is the best
because getting through this i will be
able to help millions of people who are
going through the same thing
so how do we apply it i'm going to give
you two suggestions first off
try to reframe the negativity use it as
an exercise right now just think about
something negative that happened
right now think about maybe you were
standing in line at the coffee shop and
the person was rude to
you or you stood in line at a red light
and it was really frustrating to you
you're waiting for that elevator or
you spilled coffee all over yourself
right
it's the best just reframe it just take
the negative thing that happened to you
right now today
so far or yesterday a negative
conversation anything
and just tell yourself this is the best
and try to find a reason why
and get used to that reframing every
single time something negative happens
you won't catch it all the time but the
more you practice catching it the more
you will catch it ongoing
practice it right now think about that
one thing and then think about how can
that be the best
and then find another one and how can
that be the best and the next time
you're feeling negative frustrated upset
angry how can that be the best
if you have a hard time getting out of
bed in the morning and you're frustrated
and sad and angry about yourself
if you do it like tomorrow wake up and
do it
and the next day do it get out of bed or
still suffer for the next three months
getting out of bed
understand why is it the best how is
that the best because when you figure
out how to do it
when you get out of bed you will be able
to help millions of other people
who have that same problem as you so the
struggle the fight
the effort is the best
and two think about your purpose coming
from your pain people like to avoid
their pain we want to run from our pain
we never want to remember the pain
especially entrepreneurs we like to lean
in on the positive and the optimistic
which is amazing
but the answer is to jump head into your
pain not run away from it you dive into
it
and in there is the answer for what you
should be doing with your life and your
business
write this down what is your biggest
pain
whether it was growing up whether it
happened last year like what's what are
some of the most painful moments in your
life and try to remember it then you may
have a block
you may have tried to wipe it from your
memory don't do that
that's your purpose lying in there write
down the most painful moments in your
life and then see how is that the best
not because it happened to you because
that sucked but how do you turn it from
that negative situation into you being
able to serve others that's how it
becomes the best
that painful moment that you had how can
you use that to serve other people
write that down three things i want you
to do to nurture your vision
i want you to affirm it every day affirm
it every day
and don't affirm it is i'm trying i wish
i want to i am let me hear you say i
am i am i am
i am i am i
am every single day
i am is the creative force of the
universe
whatever you attach i am to
you will become you know people say i'm
broke
oh i'm single no
i'm waiting for my ideal mate to present
himself to me in a way that i recognize
whatever you attach i
am to i'm confused no
[Music]
i am awaiting clarity in this moment
so affirm your vision every day and just
because somebody else can't see your
vision
doesn't mean that it's not a powerful
vision for you
here's another key for you never
judge your clarity on how
other people respond did you hear me
they gonna say what you doing you crazy
why are you doing that you can't do that
who told you you could do that who do
you think you are i love that one who do
you think you are
me affirm your vision
clarify your vision know what you're
doing
why you're doing it and how you're doing
it
day by day moment by moment and
sometimes
the how only shows up on a need to know
basis
don't wait for the how until you start
pursuing your vision
you understand don't wait for the house
sometimes you just have to walk blindly
but if you just do your vision every
single day
putting one foot in front of the other
committed to your desires being obedient
walking through your fears the vision
will unfold much grander
than you could have ever even imagined
or
asked for so this is what i say
to support your vision instead of
begging for it
pleading for it pray oh god please open
your please god please
oh god please please god please
oh hallelujah
be still
let your daily spiritual practice
be one of stillness and listening
listen for the instruction
instead of begging for the direction
listen be still
so many times we miss happiness because
we think it's out there
and so we pursue happiness and what we
need to discover is the fact that
happiness is not
a place that you go or a status that you
attain
happiness is an inside job that when i
am content happy satisfied
pleased within myself that everybody and
everything
will bring happiness around me just as
if i'm displeased on the inside
there's nothing that will bring me
pleasure or happiness on the outside
happiness is not an outside job
it's an inside job happiness is not
something that someone brings to me or
gives to me
it's something i bring to myself and
give myself
so give yourself today the gift of
happiness it's your choice
and guess what the moment that you are
happy within
there's a whole bunch of happiness that
you're going to experience on the
outside
oh my god i love this question
i don't think i've ever been asked this
question before i've never had an
opportunity to explain it
being the best version of you first of
all it's not
don't think of it holistic i want you to
break it down
to different parts of your life because
when you are committed to being the best
version of you
which in summary it's the you that
you're so
incredibly proud of holistically it's a
360 approach
it says i'm not perfect
so best does not mean the perfect
version of you
because i think perfection and balance
are two illusions
that are designed to help you keep
chasing something that's not even
attainable
so perfect is not attainable and balance
is not attainable
so it's perfectly managing my
imperfection
and releasing balance and having harmony
number one
but the best version of you is really
saying that in
each area of my life i'm in movement in
each area of my life i'm
an evolution in each area of my life i'm
active
i am actively participating in an
upwardly way
in an upperly mobile way in this area of
my life
times every area of my life it doesn't
necessarily mean that
you're always where you want to be but
it does mean that you're being
responsible
you're being active and you're being
proactive finances
that you're looking at your numbers just
this morning
just this morning i ran my credit score
again
i want to see what's on it i want to be
actively participating in my financial
growth
i looked at my savings i looked at my
life insurance i just looked at my
my long-term plan not necessarily
because i want to buy
another house or i want to buy a car i
just want to be on top of it
i want to be responsible for it and then
health and wellness
just yesterday i was talking to matt and
going matt
it's time for us to do another health
and wellness campaign
i don't necessarily want to do it and it
slightly to moderately scares me a bit
when i'm bringing my fitness
into a public conversation but i know
the responsible me the best version of
lisa is saying hold me accountable
hold me accountable to my fitness goals
hold me accountable to my total wellness
goals
and then last week i was just sitting
with someone saying you know what i need
to go down the list of all the checkups
that i've had
i need to make sure i'm not missing
anything relationships
i just said to a girlfriend yesterday
hold me accountable
hold me accountable to not running
i realize that i run well and i run
smoothly i run like a gazelle sometimes
when it comes to relationships you don't
it doesn't even look like i'm running
because i'm so busy
so i ask someone who knows me who knows
the love that i want
who knows my sexy excuses
i need you to hold me accountable when i
say this i want you to question it
and so while there's so much growth in
every area of my life
i'm being the best version that i know
to be because i'm active in every single
area i'm not saying i'm being the best
i am the best please don't get me wrong
with that
i'm just saying to be the best version
of myself so when you look at being the
best version of yourself
look at each part of your life and go
what am i actively doing
where you feel like i'm in the game and
it's there i'm not resigned
and i'm not praying for it to go right
or i'm not
in resignation and then complaint about
it i'm not a victim to that relationship
i'm not a victim to my finances i'm not
a victim to the relationships in my
family
i'm an active part of creating what's
occurring and it can always get better
but i'm an active part
that's being the best version of you
and waking up each morning and saying i
like me today
i got many things i can work on but i
like me today
before you ever go out on facebook or
any other social media platform
to check to see if anyone else like you
your job is to like you first
and every other like is bonus that's
stepping into the best
version of you setting long-term goals
that make your knees knock a little bit
and make your teeth chatter a little bit
those goals that you don't know
exactly how you're gonna get it done but
it's something that you want to get done
it doesn't it stretches you but it
doesn't stress you
your goals are supposed to stretch you
not
stress you those things that combination
and when you live in that capacity and
you focus and you operate in that one
that's when you're living in being the
best
version of you just think about
if you're an immigrant and you're
watching television
and you see people who can come from
white cultures with no problems
whatsoever
like the president's in-laws but
brown people coming from other countries
they're separated from their children
and and put in cages
and there's a silence there's not
millions of people protesting and saying
this is not who we are as a country
this is inhumane i believe that all of
us have a responsibility
that we want to live a life
that will outlive us the work that
you're doing
there are people that you will never
meet whose lives that you've
transformed that you you're living a
life
that will out live you just think about
the fact that this program
has given a lot of people hope and
there's hope in the future
it gives you power in the present every
40 seconds someone commits
suicide but because of something you say
or
some guess that you've invited and and
as they share their story
you interrupt that story of being
hopeless and
powerless and and not wanting to be here
anymore and because
they took the time to watch you create
an experience oliver wendell holmes said
that once a
man or woman's mind has been expanded
with an ideal concept or experience it
could never be satisfied to going
back to where it was and so at the end
of the program at the
end of one of your presentations there
are people
who because of you their lives will be
transformed and they will become
a pencil as mother teresa would say in
the hand of god
and start writing a new chapter with
their lives
so how does someone find purpose
in chaos when they can't even get out of
the thinking because they're just trying
to survive
yeah so a beautiful question my my
biggest answer is first of all i
empathize with anyone who's been in that
situation having
i can't ever say i've been in that
situation in the same way but i've
experienced similar things
you've stealing in your life yeah in my
own way and i've seen my mom go through
stuff like that
i know that my mom worked really hard to
raise me and my sister while working
you know while running around and i've
i've seen my mom be that incredible
powerhouse of a person
and the the main thing i would say is
what you can do right now
is find meaning in what you do make what
you do
meaningful passionate and purposeful you
don't need to suddenly look to become an
entrepreneur or
start a side hustle or find some more
time find meaning and the way you find
meaning
as you genuinely stop press pause for a
second
and go what am i living for like what am
i living for right now and if you're
living for your child and if you're
living
to provide and put food on the table
that is a beautiful thing that we should
celebrate more
and sometimes it takes us a moment to
stop and celebrate that and so i would
say find meaning because you can't
always find happiness you can't always
find positivity
but you can always find meaning in that
position so i'll give an example like
i lost someone really important to me a
mentor a few days back
i can't be positive about that you can't
be happy about it
yeah it's hurtful you feel sad you you
feel lost but guess what i can find
meaning in it because i can make a list
of every lesson he taught me
and make a plan to try and live every
one of those lessons wow that's
beautiful
and and so if you're in a really tough
situation right now don't look for
positivity
don't look for happiness look for
meaning the beautiful thing about
the time that we're living in now
is we can share knowledge and
experiences
and anybody with a you know a phone
an ipad or a smartphone or an android
or a computer anywhere in the world in
the kalahari desert in antarctica
can get access and get inspired
it's the best ideas in the world yeah to
get the best ideas in the world
but to see that we're no different none
of us are different
the illusion is that we're different
because we're comparing
who we are compared to the person that
we're
listening to or learning from we're
seeing the gap
and the gap is what causes us to be
uncomfortable but if we remember
we're all spiritual we're all made from
the exact
same thing you know if you think about
the human body it's made of hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen
carbon helium there's there's elements
but we came from the furnaces of stars
you can't have carbon okay in the human
body
that didn't come from the inside of a
star
helium and hydrogen is what the big bang
was initially made up of
and then as all the gases coalesced and
created stars and then galaxies
we became our flesh and blood and
everything that we became the organism
has come from the universal intelligence
that's why we're all connected
and that's why we all have the same
abilities different skills
different knowledge but the same
abilities to become
all of the ideas goals and dreams that
we have
and so we just have to say that is what
i want to trade my life for
and even though i don't know how even
though i may not feel totally
comfortable or
confident or i'm lacking certainty
let's get let's get on the path and then
we can change the world together
for the past number of years i've been
reading obituaries
and you might say robin that's negative
and i don't think it's negative i think
it's really positive
because i think few things are as
powerful to wake you up
to remind you about what's most
important to fuel your energy
to get you into the game so you let go
of your fears and you do what you need
to do
to get big things done than connecting
to your own mortality
when you realize that every single day
could be your last or when you
appreciate that no matter how long you
live
life is a short ride you just sort of
let go of the fears and you let go the
limits and you live
full-on and you seize opportunities and
you
have real conversations with real people
and you sort of wear your heart on your
sleeve and you bring on the fullness of
your authenticity
and you do whatever it takes to get your
loftiest dreams
to get done and so i read these
obituaries and it reminds me
about what life is all about and
relatively recently i've started walking
in cemeteries i was in mauritius a
little while ago it's
i don't know if you've been to mauritius
but it's this paradise on earth
it's this tiny island about four hours
off the coast of cape town
and i've been to mauritius a number of
times i was there to give a big
leadership event you know i talked about
leading without a title
so it was filled with iconic ceos and
people running
big industries and big companies and
entrepreneurs
and startup people
and it was really wonderful but i also
took about a week and a half just to
refuel
and to work on my new book and to
reconnect with my values and
to set myself up for the coming months
and
one of the things i did was i went for a
long walk
i love walking i find interesting like i
find a lot of the most creative people
the most productive people
in the planet they all have one thing in
common they have the routine of walking
on a regular basis
and so i love walking i've walked in
nature for many many years
and so here i am in mauritius and i just
started walking
and i was actually listening to an
interview
of charlie rose and steve martin
and it was done in new york in front of
an audience of a few thousand people
it was about an hour and a half long and
steve martin was talking about his
career and charlie rose is one of the
great interviewers of our time
so he was asking about how he became so
good at what he did
and his life and his love of art and
stand-up
comedy and acting i mean he you know
steve martin became an
actor after a stand-up comedian etc
and so i'm walking and the sun is
setting and i'm walking along
the indian ocean and i'm looking at the
flowers
and i get to this little village and
it's this
really um
you know this little village with a lot
of character
and as i'm walking along the edge of the
village still close to the seaside
i spot a cemetery
and i i've learned to follow my instinct
more than ever before because instinct
is more powerful than reason
and life will lead you to an interesting
place if you
stay with the flow and so i walked
towards the cemetery
and i walked into the cemetery and i
started walking
through the cemetery very respectfully
and carefully
but it was interesting to me because a
lot of the tombstones were just made of
wood
and somewhat
sadly some of the wooden crosses
were actually really really small and
you could tell
that the grave sites were of kids
and as i walked through the cemetery i
saw these
crosses and i saw some tombstones
some looked very old a few graves looked
fresh
and it reminded me really about
the shortness of life i mean marcus
aurelius has written one of my favorite
books
the meditations of marcus aurelius and
actually he didn't write it
marcus aurelius was a roman emperor and
during a long military campaign in his
journal he wrote his thoughts and his
philosophies and someone found those
diaries those journals
and made them into this book called the
meditations of marcus aurelius
and he does talk about the shortness of
life and so does
you know epitidis and a lot of the great
stoic philosophers
and being in this cemetery and walking
through it with great delicacy
it reminded me how short life is
and it reminded me we all have hopes and
dreams and we never know when
those dreams are going to get dashed and
you know we never know when our last day
will unfold
some people will wake up tomorrow
morning they'll get in their car you
know they'll take a shower they'll have
their coffee
they'll say goodbye to their loved ones
and that will be the last day that their
loved ones will ever see them
you know some people on the planet the
day after tomorrow will go into their
doctor's office
to get the result of a routine checkup
and the doctor will say sit down i've
got some sad news for you
and they'll be diagnosed with maybe some
kind of a terminal illness
i mean accidents illness
tragedy catastrophe is also a reality of
humanity
and so what i'm suggesting to you is
do whatever it takes to be in the moment
and to stay positive
and to stay on your game and to optimize
your craft
and to spend time with your loved ones
and to take care of your fitness
and to learn something new every day and
to enjoy the beauty of sunsets and
star-filled nights
and at the same time as much as possible
please do not lose perspective
stay connected to your mortality
you know steve jobs in that famous
stanford speech
said it really well you know you are
naked
you have nothing to lose and he learned
that when he connected
to his cancer and so maybe you will
install a ritual
once a month on the way home from work
you will pull over to a cemetery and
you'll spend
five minutes even in meditation
looking at the tombstones looking at the
crosses
studying the graves or whatever your
tradition
is in whatever nation you're from
because not every tradition i know
has the grave sites sometimes it's the
the funeral pyre which really
reminds me that life is really short
and you never know when your last day is
going to be
and so just build some kind of a routine
to remind you on the shortness of life
so that you
tell the people you love how you feel
about them so you write the letters that
need to be written and i know people
don't write letters but writing a letter
to someone
you need to express forgiveness to or
gratitude
to is really powerful pursue
the projects that will allow you to
be the legend of your industry chase the
passions that fuel your joy
and live every day as if it was your
last
because we never know when our last day
will show up
elon musk talks about in his business
it's all about breaking things down to
the physics
if you sell to people the physics in
your world
is psychology and understanding what
motivates them
so your company needs to have a why if
you know
simon sinek and his brilliant book start
with why
you'll know what we're talking about the
golden circle
most people know what they do they may
even know how they do it
but they oftentimes don't know why they
do it
why did we launch quest nutrition
because we wanted to end metabolic
disease
now nobody knew that from looking at a
protein bar
but our marketing material was about
that
we didn't do features and benefits we
said stop
sacrificing we said you should hold food
companies to a new standard
it's ridiculous that food companies
aren't
engineering new equipment to make food
that's both good for you
and delicious it's just ridiculous
nobody's held their feet to the fire
people have been buying the same junk
products for years they're not going to
change unless you force them to
and so we came along and said we're
going to be the bearer of standards
we know why we're doing what we're doing
so i can't release a product that has
sugar in it
why because that's not going to end
metabolic disease and that is my
driver i show up to work every day not
thinking about
making it rain and counting my money i'm
not swimming in it like scrooge mcduck
i'm coming every day thinking about two
people my mom and my sister
and i ask a very simple question is this
advantageous for my mom and my sister
yes or no if it is i do it if it's not i
don't
now a lot of times what's advantageous
for my mom and my sister was really
inexpensive it was super annoying to
have to do it because it was like you
watch your private margins like oh
god but it becomes an easy filter
and every business has to have a filter
every business needs to know what they
say yes to and what they say no to
and if you don't have that blinding
guiding light
when you scale you will fall apart and
the reason you will fall apart your
customers won't know who you are
they won't know how to communicate your
message to somebody else your employees
won't know who you are they won't know
what to communicate to each other let
alone the outside world
so it has got to be blinding you have to
be able to write it down
it has to be super clear it's got to be
direct
and it's got to be meaningful and it has
to be real
it's got to actually be something that
drives you we live in a society where
some among us are prejudiced right
so there are people who would not
traditionally hire eric thomas
but you will get to a point where nobody
else can do what i do
and your company the value of your
company is greater than your racism
uh hear what i'm telling you so you may
be racist and not want to hire
an african-american male that looks like
me but because i'm the best version of
myself
in terms of what i do online i can
compete with anybody else who's doing it
the phd i need you to hear what he's
saying the phd
was very intentional and deliberate
living a life of character
these are all things that's going to
help me out and then my relationship
with god you fit
you through now there's nothing you
could do you stop now
you stuck so it's like you you call
everybody else you might even brought
them in
and it didn't change anything so now
you're like all right last resort i got
to bring e.t in
and then i come in with the anointing
and rip shot
and rip shot
and then you like uh can we get the
retainer i'm like
we could have you could have started
with me right so i'm telling you what
he's telling me is the truth
i'm not saying oh i can't believe
they're still racist people in 2019
that has nothing to do with me that's
not my fight
my fight is being the best version of
eric thomas that's what i can control
i can't control industries i can't
control what people think or say
but what i can control is eric thomas
and so i'm telling you what he's saying
is real
cause you're like but i gotta no you
don't you don't you still in your mind
when he was saying it's like but you
don't get it
i gotta and they don't no no
you just need to get to that place where
you are
strong and when you go in you want some
jedi mind trick stuff
what does max out really stand for for
you
and when did that moment happen where
you knew that that was gonna be part of
your brand yeah um
my son's name's max so that helped um
but maxed out to me means this as you
know
um your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll
eventually possess so if you're obsessed
with what you're worried about your
fears your problems you're going to
possess those
and so i became obsessed um
the the short version is is that you
don't know this i don't talk about this
on camera very much
when i was 30 my uncle died at 50 years
old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble or
remind everybody else
my dad's brother he died at 50. sorry no
thank you i appreciate that it's a long
time ago now
and um but he was kind of with my
godfather and on my culture that's a big
deal of course might as well yeah i know
shout out uncle mike yeah mine was uncle
mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's got chills
everywhere right there
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa i thought the universe works right
wow okay you got me right there
so mine was my uncle mike
wow and no man i just touched me
so mine was my uncle mike and uh
that blows my mind right there brother
so
i'm on i'm at his funeral we're flying
back on the flight
there's this thing in your brain called
the reticular activating system it
basically filters into your awareness
what's important to you
that's why like if you buy a new car all
of a sudden you see that car
everywhere on the freeway three lanes
over on the other side boom another one
they were always there why do you see
them now it's filtered into your
importance
and heart attacks were at my he died of
a heart attack and so i'm on the
airplane and i'm listening to music and
on the screens the oprah show but i'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart
on the screen i'm like unplugged my
headphones plug it into the phone system
and it was about a new heart scan that
was happening at cedars-sinai where they
could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short i hear it and i told my
wife i said schedule me for one of those
exams
she's like it's expensive i don't care
schedule it we call it's a nine month
wait
i go i need to get in i need to get in i
keep calling the lady finally she goes
there's a cancellation tomorrow at two i
go i'll be there
so i go down for the scan and thank god
this doctor understood influence and
leverage do you do the scan
then you come back after lunch i
literally went ate a burrito
came back i wasn't in shape i'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
i'm no i'm looking for edward milot i go
it's my let you know and he goes uh he
knew
and he goes whoa i can't believe these
arteries are in that young body
wow you need to come back son now my
heart's racing i'm like what the hell's
in the skin we sit down instead of what
a normal doctor would do they just go
hey um
here's the prescription take crest store
work out eat goodbye
he understood reasons is what changes
people's lives
massive reasons not discipline reasons
and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful um
do you have kids i go yeah i go i got a
son he's one he goes that's great um do
you want to be there when he graduates
high school
i went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school i
said uh yeah he goes
okay uh is she pregnant huh i go yeah
what does she have and i said a girl you
get to a dad this is what you say he
goes would you like to walk that little
girl down the aisle on her wedding day
son
i went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes i want to be very clear with
you young man i remember this like
yesterday
because i want to be very clear with you
young man if you continue down the road
you're going
another man's going to live with your
beautiful wife in your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
going to be arm in arm with your
daughter on her wedding day not you
you'll be long gone
actually as i tell you this right now
dude right and he goes
what i'm going to get you to do is i'm
going to get you to max out your life
and your fitness
and i went give me it yeah
and he gave me exactly what i needed to
do and he said if you do this you'll
walk her down the aisle blah blah blah
from that day
when i get up like i did this morning
and i'm tired and i was late last night
and i don't want to go to the gym i
swear to you brother i swear to you i go
bella's wedding get your ass up and i go
i
i'm fit because i have massive reasons
that's why i'm fit
and that started the journey towards
maxing out every area of my life i'm
like if i can do this in my fitness i
can do this in business i can do this my
spirituality
and everything i'm not going to
shortchange myself by pretty good i'm
going to see what my real potential is
what my maximum capacity is every single
day
because at the end of my life when i do
die i have this belief that when i'm
done the lord's gonna go well done good
and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been this
is the man you were born to be this is
the man you were destined to be
this is where you could have gone but
you could have seen the memories you
could have had the people you could help
the person you could have become
meet him my obsession is that every day
i'm chasing that dude so that when i do
die we meet we're identical twins
because the bad end of a life whether it
would be at 30
50 or 150 would be i meet that guy and
we're total strangers
so i'm obsessed with meeting that guy
someday and that's what maxing out means
saying look it's good for you to go take
your place in the world have some
ambition
have some have a vision have a goal have
a strategy
try to try to be a good person and not
not because
it's your duty precisely because that's
the proper way to live we're in danger
of undermining all of that
and it's not good for people one of the
things that i've really learned for
example recently is that there's a
or learned to articulate better is that
there's a very tight relationship
between aspiration and responsibility
so let's say well the first question
might be do you need to aspire
to something and the answer is well yes
because you have to do something
okay if you just sit there you'll die
you can't just sit there you have to go
act out
in the world okay so act towards what
well that's whatever your aspiration is
you have to have an aim
okay well what should the aim be well it
should be something worth doing let's
say
what why do something that you don't
feel is worth doing what do you think's
worth doing well if you watch other
people and
you judge when they're doing something
worthwhile usually judge them positively
if you see that they're taking
responsibility
at least for themselves but you want to
be completely useless so other people
have to take care of you that's pretty
pathetic
and maybe you could get your act
together so you're taking care of
yourself and your family
and maybe you could even do better than
that and take care of yourself and your
family and your community
i want to talk to you about where you're
going and what you want to do with your
life
you see most people never go after
what they want because they don't know
every step
they have to take to get there i want
you to think
of a person going up the side of a wall
of ice
now the only rule for reaching a goal
that you have to know
is knowing where you're going and
knowing
that you're going to get there you do
not have to know
how you're going to get there now pay
attention to this for a moment
imagine the climber has all his
equipment he's got his
crampons he's got his climbing rope his
hardware
his ice axes how does he get to the top
he's standing on the ground and he's
looking at maybe
a hundred foot vertical wall of ice
he looks up and he has absolutely no
idea the path that he's going to take he
just sees himself
at the top he reaches up and he puts
one pick in and then another pick
then he raises one foot and then the
other
now he's not standing on the ground any
longer
he suspended on the wall on a vertical
wall of ice
that goes up for a hundred feet he
adapts to the changes
that is taking place in his environment
and then and
only then does he see the next step
and he moves this pick then this pick
then this foot then this foot
now that's how he gets to the top a step
at a time
and that's how you're going to get to
your goal you just have to know
the first step to take and when you take
that step
you're going to find that your
conditions your circumstance and
environment will change
then you see how you have to make
the next step it's a matter of adapting
all the time
you only have to know two things you
have to know where you're going and you
have to know that you're going to get
there
you've got to see it in your mind now
this is the beautiful scenario
this is what it's all about save that in
your mind
and think of it often think every time
you think of your goal and you're trying
to figure out how you're going to do it
think of that vertical wall of ice
what's the next step that's all you
really have to know
one step at a time and you'll get to
wherever you're going
that's how hillary got to the top of
mount everest i was bartending
at night waiting tables doing assistant
work like i was basically working
24 7. you know in the evenings and
weekends it was all
how can i just make money to pay my rent
and put food on the table and in the
days i was really working my buns off
trying to
create content create a newsletter get
coaching clients actually start working
with people
and um when i got engaged really young i
was about 23 years old
and the guy was a sweetheart but i
realized
pretty quickly i didn't want to marry
him this was not the person i was meant
to spend the rest of my life with
but we lived in this tiny one-room
studio in the west village
and our money was already co-mingled
and so i was terrified because
i felt like i made this huge mistake
here i am trying to become a life coach
and clearly
i have a lot to figure out about life
i knew i needed to get out of this
relationship but i didn't i didn't know
how to
untangle what i had created this big
mess and so
um i knew once i broke off that
engagement i needed to actually
physically leave that environment that
was the only way i was going to get to
move on
and so i called my parents in new jersey
and i said i hate to say this but i
have to move home i was so upset i just
felt like a total failure i felt like a
horrible person
for breaking this guy's heart and
it was just it was a mess like i just
felt like such a failure on
every single level the fact that i
couldn't support myself yet
the fact that i had to go back to jersey
the fact that i
felt like i you know did a number on
this guy's life
and it was really humbling but you know
at the end of that it made me realize
i'm more committed than
ever to figure out what it takes to make
my life work and then also to be able to
share those lessons with other people so
hopefully they didn't have to go through
the mess that i created if i could save
people learning curve
that was going to be awesome and i think
i was home maybe like two or three
months
something like that emotionally i had to
heal and just kind of get myself
re-situated and you know find a new
living
a place to live in the city and get back
on my feet but it was
probably one of the best things that
ever happened to me because it got me
re-grounded in my own power
and made me realize that if everything
falls apart
which it sometimes does there's always a
way to get back on your feet
if you want to learn how to stop wasting
your life away check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the number one
mistake
that people are making in life today and
it's and it's just so unbelievably
obvious
is they're living life in the middle